extreme drought conditions persist in
northern mexico
the city of monterrey home to some 5
million people has been particularly
hard hit
people
people are fighting over the water the
trucks arrive and people don't respect
the line it's chaos in our neighborhood
it's sad but what can we do we need a
miracle
these are the driest conditions the
region has seen in 30 years with
recorded rainfall levels far below
average
during a recent visit to monterrey
mexico's president andres manuel lopez
obrador promised to continue to provide
emergency government assistance
i believe this situation will help lead
everyone towards participating in the
conservation of water so that we will be
more conscious about the importance of
this vital resource
experts say as much as 65 percent of
mexico's territory is currently
experiencing moderate to severe drought
conditions
they attribute it in part to this year's
unseasonable la nina weather pattern
which has pushed rain and cooler
temperatures further north
extreme heat and a lack of rain are also
wreaking havoc across the border in the
united states prompting action from
officials there the growing drought
crisis is fueled by the impacts of
climate change including extreme heat
low precipitation
in turn severe drought conditions that
perpetuate the climate crisis by
increasing wildfire risk affecting crop
yields and ultimately disrupting our
ecosystems and the climate as a whole
u.s states like arizona and nevada have
already been asked to cut back what they
take from the drought-stricken colorado
river which supplies water to some 40
million people across seven u.s states
and to communities in northwestern
mexico
less water from the colorado river is
also raising longer term concerns in
both the u.s and mexico over potential
food shortages if action is not taken to
address the crisis manuel rapalo al
jazeera mexico city